hello everyone and welcome to the second
half of the 2013 candidates tournament
it's a very interesting game between
Vladimir Kramnik and Peter Svidler now
before we start the game or start with
anything let's just check out the
standings before we started the game so
after seven rounds we finish the first
half of the tournament and it scores
cousin and Aragon in the lead then
wheeler and kramnik with three and a
half points so two of them are playing
this game if either of them wins then he
is going to get very close to Magnus
Carlsen and level orange and then
algebra English with three and Gelfand
and Avenger with two and a half it's a
very interesting game that you know
brought up a lot of questions that after
after it was played but we will address
that matter after we see the game as
this is very important and the photos we
have from this round are also very
important to decide on this matter but
also we will discuss this after the game
so here we have a nice photo of Peter
Svidler here you can see him preparing
his black pieces he's you know he's
preparing that night night and g8 he
knows that his first move will be nice
to have six and you know he's making
sure that everything is ready and then
we have a very nice close-up of Vladimir
Kramnik here and also here we have a
nice photo from the middle game it's a
very hard to really figure out what's
going on here it seems like someone in
the audience is being very loud and
chronic is like guys not cool you know
Peters trying to concentrate but you
know so it's very hard to actually
figure out what's going on in the photos
but that being said let's see this game
so it's very interesting after we see
that the opening moves d4 Knight to f6
c4 g6 Knight to c3 and d5 it's the groom
fell defense and the Peter Svidler was
known to be a groom for specialist and
he really enjoyed playing the groom felt
but Vladimir Kramnik was known to be a
groom felt killer so definitely an
interesting matchup and you'll see that
after a couple more moves seek after son
b5 Knight captures efore this is the
main line Knight captures pawn captures
and
to g7 we had a knight to f3 c5 Bishop to
e3 and Queen to a5 Queen to d2 and this
is the exact same position Vladimir
Kramnik had with the white pieces when
he played his World Chess Championship
match against Garak as part of it this
is a position from Game two of their
match and Vladimir Kramnik won that game
very nicely with the white pieces it's
one of the two games kramnik won in that
match so chronic is very familiar how to
play against the groom field and
especially with this position here at
Wheeler chose
Knight to c6 in in their World Chess
Championship match at Kasparov continued
with Bishop to g4 then the game
continued rook to be 1 and so on and so
on so here
the game takes a new approach Knight to
c6 we look to see one pawn captures pawn
captures and immediately a trade of
Queens Queen captures King captures now
we have castles and d5 attacking the
knight on c6 and rook to d8 pinning the
pawn so black doesn't immediately have
to react to this and here we have a move
King to c2 and this King to see to move
is a move kramnik says that he already
had in his home
preparation while he was preparing for
his game against Garrick as part of 13
years ago so definitely definitely
fiddler is out prepared in this matchup
ninth to e5 Knight captures Bishop
captures and Bishop to c4 Bishop to d7
f4 now kicking the bishop back Bishop to
d6 and King to b3 so as you can see the
material is completely equal on the
board both players have the bishop
prepare but there is a thing you can
realize is that White's King is a much
more active and black does have
two-to-one advantage considering pawns
on the Queen side so this is something
black will often try to use as a winning
method you know just exchange one of the
points and then push the remaining
passed pawn but now that the white
already has a king here very active it's
going to be very hard to utilise this
advantage on the Queen side and on the
other hand White has a very strong
center here so we have f6 Maddaloni 5 in
the future
a4
rook D to C 8 and H for now kramnik will
definitely want to play h5 to break open
on the Kings side rook a to b 8 and now
Bishop to b5 Bishop captures pawn
captures in a6 and here we have b6 and
chronic now successfully locks down the
Queen side and will transfer the game
over to the Kings side King to have
seven we have h5 now row captures on c1
H captures on g6 first and in between
move King captures on g6 and Bishop
captures on c1 we have worked to g8 and
now g4 and definitely sweeter would
enjoy moving the skin so there would be
an attack from the rook towards the g4
pawn so first he pushes h6 I'm making
room for the King on h7 and you're
waiting to see what what we'll do and
this is a very interesting position for
you to analyze it's white is somewhat
better here he's more active but still
making any progress in this position
requires like surgical precision so it's
a very nice position for you to to pause
the video and try to find try to find
the move how do you push for push for
advantage here so I will give it a
couple of seconds for you to decide
where you want to check it out I mean
it's a if you enjoy end games you you're
gonna enjoy how to make progress here so
for those of you who were able to do
this congratulations you're an excellent
end game player and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show
here chronic continued with a rope to h5
and group to h5 is indeed is indeed the
strongest move recommended by the engine
if you found something like f5 this does
check out the king and open up the
attack towards the h6 spawn but it
doesn't really do anything after him to
f7 if you captured and black captures on
g4 nothing really going on there and and
if you try to protect it to capture next
then h5 and you're really not not
getting anything here after after a
couple of exchanges Bishop to g3 and now
as the bishop is covering both h4 and h2
white is actually losing because this
pawn is now free to march forward or all
the way to h1
so you know it seems like seems like a
trivial idea but they're definitely
worth mentioning
so after this h6 move rook to h5 Luke to
h5 preparing a e5 a very important
central break King to f7 sorry King to
f7 and now b5 you don't really gain
anything by captures captures you'd
still have to pretty much decide the
same thing so after E 5 Bishop to c5
now Sevilla is attacking the g4 pawn and
also the b6 pawn here we have e 6 first
this comes with check King to f8 and now
again what do you do here as white if
you if you decide for example to capture
and allow rook captures capture here
capture here and let's say checks checks
you you don't really have a way of
winning this position Bishop to a3
Bishop to d6
you don't you you can't allow white to
grab the e7 pawn after captures captures
the position gets pretty much blocked
after the King comes to e7 there's no
way for white to break through white
always half that has to keep an eye on
this past a pawn and there's really no
way for white to win this
so after this King to f8 move rook to h4
it's much more important to keep an eye
on this g4 pawn and now a sweedler has
to decide what to do here does he want
to grab the b6 Pony mediately the engine
does enjoy the smooth but sweedler
probably didn't want to allow bush of 2
a 3 and then chronic would be able to
start pushing his pawns so first King to
g7 preparing rook to d8 there's also the
matter of the d5 pawn so sweedler will
will grab his pawn we have f5 now rook
to d8 and Bishop captures on h6 with
check coming to g8 now comes King to c4
and now the king is guarding in the d5 1
so now Bishop captures on b6 and s
whittler does have to pass pawns on the
Queen side and it seems like you know
there is there is compensation for for
the Cramton position
but there's actually a forced win here
for Vladimir Kramnik
and also a very nice position for you to
to pause the video and figure out how to
proceed in this position as you will
most likely
I find yourself in in similar situations
like these like this so for those of you
who were able to find it
congratulations once again you're in
excellent and game player and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
at the move you have to find this g5 it
seems pretty natural but you know still
if you found the continuation then then
it's pretty much pretty much that's it
you are an excellent player
the idea is after half captures simply
Bishop captures and now simply f6 is
coming and there's really nothing black
can do here now whatever you play of
course Bishop captures an e7 is a threat
after the defended f6 is coming
nevertheless f7 is a threat after you
capture there's really no defense
against rook to e8 checkmate that's
that's game over
so after g5 Bishop to f2 was played by
cellular attacking the rook but now
comes rope to g4 we have King to h7 and
now G captures on f6 given up the bishop
it doesn't matter what black does here
even if you capture the bishop PS you
are off a piece but simply d6 and
there's simply too many points for black
to stop all of them he captures and I
simply push the pawn after rook moves
you push another pawn and you get a
queen and you don't even have to grab
the rope here you're simply checkmate in
black so after G captures on f6 we have
each captures on f6 and now II 7r up to
see it this comes with check King b3 and
after Bishop to c5 simply rook the c4
was played and it was in this position
that that Peter Svidler resigned the
game because whatever he does the game
is simply lost the simple rook captures
on c5 wins then the pawns are marching
forward there's their there is no move
black can't even make here that that
would make sense so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it it's only one
game from round 8 but we will show all
four games from round 8 as all four of
them are very interesting and have some
very interesting stories behind them and
a lot of a lot of people after this game
was played they they started talking
like oh it's the Bobby Fischer scenario
all over again
the Russians are starting to play as one
you know Spiller through this game so so
his fellow Russian can I can catch up to
Carson and and Levon Aronian and as as
comic still has the face good is Chuck
in the second part of the tournament
that that will surely be another point
for Vladimir Kramnik and you know now
people you know people like like to talk
about things like this but I definitely
don't think this is the case because you
had a couple of couple of moments where
you had to find for example that rook to
h5 move that's simply that's simply
brilliant play by Vladimir Kramnik and
there is no move that that Spiller
actually blundered he was just then in a
difficult position with with little time
on the clock and he had to make some
extremely precise moves and his moves
were not bad or mistakes or blunders or
anything they just weren't the top you
know like top top moves so a chronic
always played the top move and you know
after some 10 moves that really does
does doesn't matter and another thing I
mean look at this look at this photo
it's a photo from thriller before the
game this does not look like someone who
is ordered to throw a game against
laulima cramming he's very happy he's
very happy to play this game you know
making making ready to play that in the
first night move so that definitely
doesn't seem like it and look at this we
have a photo of the this is chronic and
Fiddler's after the game in the press
conference now they definitely don't
look like some people who who agreed to
make this game look this way
chronic I mean chronic is happy he won
the game but he's also sad for his for
his fellow Russian and swimmer
definitely you know really really looks
sad for losing this game so I don't
think there's anything to those stories
but you know that's I mean the Internet
is a wonderful place where everyone can
share their opinions so you do share
your opinions in the comments as well I
would like to thank a Mario anything OSA
Yousef or kabbani and Gabe or Tony and
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon with a
came from around eight of the 2018
candidates tournament thank you all and
I'll see you soon